dad's home come on sit down
is granny not joining us again she's
online
I'll check with her don't bother I just
called her on a mobile she's shopping in
Barcelona calling her on her mobile from
Spain she's too cheap to do that from
abroad that would cost her more than a
pair of her fancy shoes and some years
for you if you're traveling in the EU
calling or going online with your mobile
it's now a lot cheaper so if you intend
to go to Spain don't hesitate to keep in
touch with your family ok I'm sorry I
lied but I just couldn't tell you about
Rodrigo before Rodrigo
my new boyfriend boyfriend I met Rodrigo
when he was here on business it just
clicked between us I decided to spend
the summer holidays with him in Spain
but I couldn't tell you since it's so
cheap now I can call you whenever I want
how did you know it was so cheap you
didn't hear about it
Rodrigo told me he saved so much money
on roaming he bought me this smartphone
remember roaming on your phone is
cheaper now in Europe but as of the 1st
of July mobile data is too